hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm going to be
checking out the trailer for five nights
at Freddy's part 3 I played the first
one the second one it wasn't much
different it was a little scarier I
guess but I make sure so to see if they
added anything you did this
sweet that was um good teas i mean scary
still it wasn't like terrifying or
anything but it's it's a good teaser
trailer
it's just reestablishing what we already
know about five nights at freddy's i do
want to see some things that do show how
this one's gonna be different because i
don't want it to just be on repeat every
single game i would like to see i'm sure
there's gonna be some new animatronics
I'm sure Freddy's going to look a little
different I mean the trailer just really
defies that hey the creepiness is still
gonna be there five nights at Freddy's
is that game where I'm like this sounds
stupid and then whenever I play it I'm
like I am ready to [ __ ] my pants I have
shed my pants several times Hanes
underwear is now ruined it is a good
suspenseful game you know causes you to
be a little quick on your feet and it's
fun it's fun it's a funny game at times
too and I think it's clever how you
don't see the main character you're
playing as because I really allows you
to live vicariously through the role
from just first-person point of view you
know me yeah we are you say the traitors
I really show you much else anyway guys
thanks for telling me that trailer was
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where
there is so much [ __ ] on here so much
[ __ ] I put out so many videos and people
are still like you're late on requests
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
Joshua Locklear
hey Ryan think you give my page a
shout-out in your next video I would
like people to know my fan trailers
exist also your reactions are bomb
diggity people don't say that anymore do
they
crap Joshua Locklear has an awesome
channel war fighter two six eight is the
username he does fan trailers I've seen
them they're fantastic they really do
capture the spirit that a fan would want
from it I'm sorry I'm trying no not
really I could try a little harder